okay hello everyone i
am rafael malbrew a clinical laboratory
animal veterinarian at the abigail
wexner research institute
um with nationwide children's hospital
here in columbus ohio
and i have the honor of speaking to you
all a little bit
about um some of the findings and
updates that we have made at our
facility
and along with some colleagues using
some household products to improve
rodent aseptic surgery
um and so one of the first things i
always like to lead off with
is that you know a disclaimer is i don't
have any stock or any financial gain
associated with press and seal or
reynolds wrap all the information i'll
be sharing here today
is literally just from an academic
standpoint of just sharing some
knowledge and things that we've learned
with using some of these items in trying
to improve
compliance and technique within rodent
surgery
and so for outline of the talk i'll give
you a little introduction
about why and how this kind of came to
be
for using these household goods for
something such as aseptic rodent surgery
i'll also touch a little bit on the
background with some of the research
that
we have done just kind of looking at the
sterility validation
and also some other benefits from some
of these products such as
heat retention thermal regulation and
then
i definitely will will highlight some
takeaways that
you all can can use from day one after
hearing this talk at your respective
institutions of how to implement
using both of these products within
rodent surgery
um some of the learning objectives i'm
hoping that everyone will gain
are specifically some of the methods on
how
aseptically how to aseptically use cling
film
and rodent surgeries uh the precious
still specifically
some methods on how to aseptically use
foil the reynolds wrap forward surgery
as well
and then also discuss some long-term and
short-term benefits to using both of
these
within your facilities so just give an
introduction you know the common
question i get is
how did this all start why press and
seal
why foil and quite honestly a lot of it
came just from
some organic conversations with with
colleagues of
using these products for alternative
alternative means at our homes
right um so i always laugh when i see
these images of
of the dog with his uh present seal
booties going out into the snow
um or for someone that was doing some
painting at home and
wanted to protect certain items such as
the toilet here and
present field was a very cheap and
manageable item that was
in the pantry to be able to use for
something like that but on a more
serious note
um uh historically when comp med was
around this list served for laboratory
animal veterinarians internationally
there was definitely some discussion of
institutions um
who were using this and trying to get a
feel for how many people were using this
and how
they were using at the respective
institutions for rodent surgery as a
draping
material so that also kind of sparked
our interest to dive in a little bit
deeper
and perform a couple of studies to
validate um
uh using these products um in our
facilities and so
one thing we we've always kept in mind
kind of throughout this entire
adventure as we call it uh with
precision foil is
remembering um our regulatory uh
documents
and and groups and so you know when we
think about what the guide says
regarding aseptic technique
you know it's something that should be
should be followed
for all survival surgeries um and that
the failure to do so
may lead to negative consequences right
um
or your surgical success animal welfare
and research results so this is
something that's always been in the back
of our minds or just trying to if we can
find creative ways to use this in our
own homes
could we also do this in a research
facility and also help
reduce any compliance issues are
perioperative complications that um
sometimes researchers face
when we're doing invasive procedures
on rodents and so i think one thing we
our team always discussed and um this is
something that's probably not foreign to
to most of our our listeners folks
listen to this talk and that's
the research surgeon right and so it's a
very unique
um group or or
description of the individual performing
the procedure on rodents right in the
lab animal setting it's a little bit
different
and i think it's this concept of the
solo surgeon
right so it's often at times it's the
principal investigator that
scientist or a lab member who's
performed these procedures right and so
they have to be the anesthesiologist
um they're the surgeon you know doing
these very invasive
delicate procedures and also their own
assistant right having to open
up suture or more scalpel blades or
whatever piece of equipment
that they're needing to handle while
also operating on this animal
and so obviously uh with something like
that that can definitely lead to several
complications it can it can open the
doors for breaking sterility or breaking
that aseptic technique
and so again thinking about taking a
step back and saying what are some you
know there's several products out there
that
investigators can purchase that are
sterile straight out the box
to use to kind of help improve their
aseptic technique
um but a lot of times these things are
costly um and definitely now in
dealing with the pandemic right that has
definitely
changed and resources and finances have
definitely been a a heavy factor for
how people operate how labs operate you
know and that's just be perfectly
perfectly honest and even just even
prior to this with with
funding so we were looking for some ways
on how to improve
compliance and improve aseptic technique
in in rodents
and holding it up to the kind of that
same standard of what we do in our
here in at least in the states uh with
our usda covered species when it comes
to surgery so
that's where a lot of this discussion
and our background of
how we got into exploring some of these
alternative methods to help improve
success for the solo surgeon working in
the lab animal facility
and so this was our goal was how can we
take
some of these household products um
right that most people have in their
pantry and they're covered at home
and use them and for high level
surgeries you know
and so you know some some of the things
that we
saw early on or that the benefits are
that
both of these products are inexpensive
they're readily available you can go to
the
target down the street um and picking up
a box for
less than you know four dollars um you
know there was this
um hypothesis and a lot of groups had
did some preliminary things of
essentially suggesting that it was
sterile it's sterile right out of the
box you don't have to actually gas
sterilize it
and there are there were you know still
are gas
sterilized samples that you can purchase
and there was this other concept of
could this also help with
heat retention uh for for these
uh for these animals when used as a
drape material
uh right and one of the biggest things
we saw with press and seal um not
necessarily with reynolds wrap but it's
that it's transparent
so when you drape the entire animal you
can actually visualize them
which is a great thing so you can see
them breathing again that solo surgeon
that's doing the
anesthesia being the anesthetist right
and also doing the surgery can perform
their surgery but also make sure they're
monitoring the animal and looking at
respirations and things of that nature
so with all that these kind of ideas and
us
um jumping in a little bit more trying
to to figure out what are the next steps
you know how do we
investigate these products further to be
able to provide information to
our institutional animal care and use
committee right
to these groups to support using this
for rodents and surgery that it is
indeed
something that's safe and going to
benefit
all parties so um we've recently uh
published a couple of papers that
support
um sterility of of press and seal
and this was kind of our first
introductory uh study that we performed
and that was the biggest question that
you know the iacooks have had is is
this stuff sterile you know is it
straight out the box you know is it
going to introduce any kind of pathogens
infectious agents
uh that are going to cause harm or um
any anything similar to that for these
animals right and so
in this study we took ten ten present
steel boxes from an assortment of
different places
different lot numbers and we used to do
two different
uh testing modalities to assess the
sterility and that was atp
swaps and rodek plates and we did this
because most lab animal facilities have
these two types of modalities
in-house for other type of um kind of
quality assurance
practices that they're doing at their
respective facilities
and so what we did is essentially tested
them on day zero day 14
day 28 throughout the study i'm using a
few different modalities to assess if
they're we
if we got any growth you know if we had
any um high numbers of the relative
light units for the atp equipment and
you can see down below
um to to my left is kind of a diagram
out of the paper that showed you our
testing modalities and
the zigzag pattern so we assessed back
the front
the box um had um also had a negative
control just also testing just routine
sterile paper drapes
um but essentially you can see from
table one here to my right
is that we really had limited growth
throughout the entire
throughout the entire study up to 28
days um one thing i also noticed that we
actually kept these boxes
open and we kept them maintained in a in
one of our training facilities
that has very high volume of high
traffic of people coming in so there's
there's probably dust flying everywhere
and so this was equivalent to if a
researcher purchased this and just kept
it on the shelf in their lab
um kind of trying to simulate that same
type of setting
and really throughout up to 28 days we
had minimal
bacterial growth as as shown in
in this in table one and even some of
the pathogens as you can see so we did
grow a couple of organisms
right throughout this process and so the
next question was okay well
are how important are these are these
organisms right
are there any reports that these have
even caused any type of spontaneous
disease
in rodent populations or even human
populations
um and so one thing we found is that a
lot of these so example like the the
staff
species below these are things that are
actually commensal on
human skin and so we we actually were
pretty suspicious that this was actually
just
more contamination from us in our in our
culturing processes
when we were going through uh through
the study and so the takeaway
essentially from this study is that
the results supported that the use of
cling film which is depressant seals the
only thing we tested type of cling film
from this study so we do have to
specify that that it can be used as an
acceptable alternative to the
traditional stereotraits through
enrolling aseptic surgery
um and so so this was huge because this
is um something that
again it's translucent so you can see
the animal um
it actually adheres very nicely to the
table and actually almost kind of serves
as
kind of restraint devices for these
animals while they're down i'm on the
table on the heating pad
um and then it's it's economical so um
it's definitely easier easy for us to go
and have a conversation with an
investigator saying hey
we want you to to use draping material a
and
once you press and seal they'll
definitely go to target and buy that
versus
you know spending several hundreds of
dollars on things that are pre-packaged
and
a paper drape that's already sterile so
this was this was a huge finding and
also provided information for our ayaka
to support this becoming something we
implemented in our facility
so the next question we get a lot of
times is how do you even use this stuff
so okay hey
got over that hurdle we know that it's
you know it
it's essentially sterile straight out of
the box how do i use it
um so and where do i use it so a lot of
ways that
the colleagues who have been involved in
these studies and at our various
institutions use it is obviously to
drape the entire animal as you see uh to
my right here
so this whole table is actually draped
so the instruments are sitting on press
and seal
the animal is straight them the heating
pad is covered so
essentially it lies a nice sterile
barrier for a surgeon to be able to
to operate right also again we talked
about this concept of the solo surgeon
so being able to actually place this on
top of the vaporizer
um if they have to change the
anaesthetic plane or
you know level that they like to
maintain the animal you're able to do
that without breaking sterility
um and maintaining that aseptic
technique so this is
something that has been huge um it's
something that we have definitely
found a lot of researchers like again
because of the pricing and it's easy to
use and hey
if they break seriously they just rip it
off and put a new piece on
but it allows them again to be able to
be that solo surgeon to be successful
without breaking sterility
also placing it on things such as like
you saw there's an anesthesia unit
obviously
and the table but also things such as
the light you know a lot of times you
need
light to do these procedures and so this
also helps the surgeon be able to
manipulate
move things around while again not
breaking that sterility
so the next step was okay we found out
that
the press and seal is indeed something
that is essentially sterile
out of the box straight out of the out
of your your neighborhood grocery store
um and can be used in a in a multitude
of different uh settings
okay so how about foil and is it the
same can we do the same thing with it
and people were like well
are you going to drape the animal in
this and it's like no no
no we're not but the idea of using foil
is because some
one thing that we found from from
colleagues is that by repeated use of
the present seal it does leave a little
bit of a residue
on certain equipment and so obviously
things that are
really expensive items such as the
anesthesia unit or
there's a special table you're working
on you may not want to use
this material but it does come off
actually just using 70
isopropyl alcohol you can actually wipe
that off but just to avoid that it's
like
why don't we just use foil for these
things such as light handles
such as the anesthesia units and and so
forth so
what we did is use we we used to kind of
the same kind of
experimental design um for the rental
trap
foil and again rentals wrap foil just
like the press and seal glass
press and seal is the only type of this
product that we
we tested so we can only speak on
reynolds wrap but again we got 10 boxes
from a variety of different places
different lot numbers
um and we use the same two concepts atp
swaps and row deck plates to assess them
for their sterility
and so we did this on day 0 14 28
and then six months out here and he's in
the same kind of
zigzag pattern with the atp swabs front
and back
using our rodek plates on the front and
back to really get a good representation
of that and again these boxes were
maintained in
a in a space that is high traffic a lot
of people coming out and we left them
essentially essentially open during
every step
of this experiment and again what did we
find
for our atp numbers i mean essentially
no
no value there and very minimum
to none growth on the on the on the
reynolds rap itself from a pathological
standpoint
and again the organisms that we grew
here um
were of the bacillus genus
and some of these things are actually um
um found in
aquatic and terrestrial type of
environment so again this was one thing
that we thought was just another
contamination um during some of our our
culturing and
data collection processes so based off
this
information and what we gained from from
this study we also confirmed that
with the minimal bacterial growth that
was shown um on the tested samples it
does support again
using this product as a sterile burial
on non-sterile surfaces
during aseptic loading surgery and so
the idea
here of using things like this again in
addition to them being
economically pleasing for a lot of
people to be able to purchase these
versus some of these
expensive type of items out there is you
know we're just trying to help improve
compliance you know one of
our colleagues his favorite saying is
the solution to pollution is dilution so
the idea is that we're setting up these
these barriers and these practices to
really help
pis that solo surgeon remain
it remain and keep their aseptic
technique to reduce any type of harm or
any kind of posterior complications that
can come out of something like that
so again the next question we get is how
do you even you how the heck do you use
foil
you know in a rodent surgery setup so
this is a diagram again from this paper
that we
that we use to kind of demonstrate how
you could do this right so
placing it on the the nozzle for again
the top of the vaporizer for your
anesthesia unit
on the knob for the flow meter for
oxygen
um a lot of times folks are working with
need to use high magnification type of
instruments and
special lighting so on the lighting
handles i love this picture as well it's
because again
that solo surgeon they might be
documenting certain parameters or
whatever they're looking for so actually
wrap an entire pin
um in foil as well and so
these are just a few not all examples of
how folks
are using a foil of the rental trap
specifically
to help improve their rodent aseptic
techniques and again
we show that this straight out of the
box it doesn't have to be
sterilized that it's essentially sterile
so it is safe and it's not
going to introduce any unwanted
pathogens this is an example
um i know a lot of facilities have have
places that are doing using
these stereotaxic devices right and so
this is just an example of showing that
every
every every now uh every every handle
bar essentially aspect you can you can
wrap this in foil
and again it's serving as a barrier to
prevent any type of
sterility breakage that could introduce
any kind of pathogen so again allowing
that solo surgeon to be
to work solo how many be efficient
again a lot of things you know if you're
working at a facility where you know
folks are really doing some really
invasive procedures or
um you know doing things such as putting
a jugular catheter in a mouse
that takes that takes a magnification
device right like a microscope so
um obviously sometimes they're working
in the microscope they're coming out of
it to be able to assess and kind of get
their bearings
you can easily see how someone can break
sterility here but using something as
simple as foil or even present seal
works really well to be able to put on
these knobs to put actually on the
optics
on the eyepiece so that again they can
remain their sterility while also
performing their procedure so this is
something we found that
that folks really like and has really
improved
their success and any kind of preventing
any kind of unwanted post
post-operative complications um
so we kind of solve these mysteries of
present seal
the rental trap foil you know are these
things indeed sterile are they indeed
safe to use
and then how do you effectively use them
um in your in your facility so we check
we check those boxes
but one thing we also notice as a
benefit for using present seal
specifically
is the impact on the body temperature
for the animal
and as many of you probably know when
operating on any type of
small mammal definitely rodents i mean
as soon as you make any
type of a penetration to the body cavity
especially peritoneal cavity
their heat just drops their core body
temperature it just it just plummets
and obviously hypothermia is something
that can definitely lead to negative
impacts on research and
even ultimately lend to unwanted deaths
for for animals in a surgical procedure
and one thing we found just from using
it within our facilities is that it does
help
with heat retention and thermal
regulation but we really need to prove
this we didn't have enough
data to solidly say that this was just
more you know
in real time in the clinical setting we
were seeing these things and actually
seeing animals recover
a lot faster um so this is what we
sought off to do and so we wanted to
make sure that we did our due diligence
to answer this question and provide
again some more supportive information
for
um icons those institutional regulatory
committees
that are that are proving these
protocols and these procedures sops on
rodent surgery
of the benefits of using something such
as press and seal so
um this is one of our most recent papers
that will be coming out um next
and next month edition of j last but
essentially what we did is is
sought out to actually evaluate the
effects of different draping materials
on inter intraoperative rectal and
surface body temperatures
so we essentially compared cling film
depressant seal to conventional paper
drape as you see below here
from halyard and we also had a group of
node rate
and so we actually went through our
routine
pre-surgical planning and procedure of
sedating the animal
prepping them appropriately shaving and
then we actually made an incision
into the abdominal cavity so we just did
a
laparotomy and then we maintained the
animal
i'm on a recirculating heating blanket
with press and seal
or the paper drape or no drape and then
we monitor the body temperatures for
over a 35 minute
period and the two modalities we use
to actually obtain the of the rectal
temperatures
um and just the body temperature in
general uh were this kind of this skin
sensor device which is commonly used
in people and then an infrared
temperature device and we picked these
because mainly because
a lot of people have these in these
facilities uh they're cheap
and and actually with the skin device we
got really creative because we if you
just remove the pad
there's this little this little probe
that's actually the sensor part that's
actually
obtaining the temperature and this is so
small and it perfectly fits within the
rectum of the mouth
and the nice thing about is that it
hooks up to most
of the common surgical kind of parameter
devices that most folks have in their
facilities so something like a surge
event
monitor um it plugs into there and so it
actually will give you read out
that temperature so most people we
thought most people have this in their
facilities just
less of another thing that they have to
go and purchase but there are a variety
of other
thermal regulation and temperature
monitoring devices that are available
for for rodents so what did we find out
so this is this this image here and this
data set is showing rectal temperatures
right and the biggest thing i want to
point out from here is if you look at
the red triangle
that's representing the the cling film
drape over this 35 minute period
and the most interesting thing and most
positive thing we saw is that over the
from the start of this
procedure making that incision
maintaining this animal again it was on
a heating pad
recirculating water blanket heating pad
he saw this kind of constant trend of
increase
of the core body temperature up almost
to the 93 degrees fahrenheit mark
whereas with no drape not using any
draping material at all i mean it
dropped down to the low
uh low low 90s high high 80s
and obviously something like again we
talked about is as hypothermia is
definitely something that can end the
negative impact so post-surgically
uh for these animals having at least
some kind of draping material like paper
drape
also uh maintain at least above 90 um
getting up to
close to like 92 mark here but again
biggest takeaway is that the clean film
did the best best job out of what we
tested
of maintaining a higher uh body
temperature and again this is by using
the rectal temperatures using that that
probe sensor that
we showed in the previous images now
with the infrared temperatures
um obviously there is some data already
out there about these
these devices um not being as accurate
and that's definitely what we saw here
and so this
this graph essentially again supported
that the present seal
gave us the highest uh temperature again
degree in degrees fahrenheit and if you
look at the 35 minute mark it was almost
close to 92 degrees fahrenheit
but it was a little interesting
interesting to see that the node rate
versus the paper drape that
looking at that difference but again we
think a lot of this was just the
variability in using the infrared
handheld and some those just not being
as accurate um so again that rectal cord
that rectal temperature is gonna
um any of those type of modalities
essentially gonna give you a more
accurate
uh reading but again press and seal did
the best job at
maintaining that uh that body
temperature and if you recall back to
the previous image
um it actually had a more upper upper
trend throughout that
now takeaways from from from this study
um again just to keep it simple using uh
draping material does
has an effect on the body temperature
and we did find that
paper drape or even just routine clean
the press and seal clean film
is is much better and we did find
significance to having no drape at all
so using some type of draping material
is important right so a that's what we
found but
we found that the cling film obviously
uh was was a lot better in actually
maintaining a higher
body temperature um second
to that um the the practicality of the
rectal probe
and again it was very nice because this
was something that was compatible with a
lot of the common
uh vital monitor machines that most
people will have in their
in their facilities so again really
really
strong suggestive evidence and data
saying hey this presence seal is a
really good product not only is it
sterile not only is it translucent so
you can see the animal why you perform
the procedure
but it helps to maintain a nice body
temperature
that doesn't allow them to overheat as
well i think that's another important
thing to
to mention whereas you know some of you
may
have actually seen where uh maybe that
solo surgeon has no drape the animals
just on at least they have some heat
supplementation but they don't have any
drape
this kind of really just showed us too i
mean how how far down the temperature
can drop
which is pretty interesting not some
future studies you know one thing we did
not look at but we are
working to do a couple of studies is
obviously the effects on recovery
so looking at recovery times and just
from some anecdotal
kind of real-time clinical things i've
seen it it really appears to help
actually in in decreasing and having
those shortened recovery times using the
presence seal
and obviously looking at surgical
outcomes so these are some future things
we're looking to actually get some hard
data on to provide
for the field um then the other is just
also continue to investigate
and look at these commercial road and
temperature modern devices that are out
there
so there's a lot coming out on the
market and i think it's some some really
good products that are going to really
um help just again and that solo surgeon
being successful and also just helping
that laboratory animal veterinarian all
these regulatory groups that are
providing oversight
help which is compliance decreasing
compliance concerns
and so uh one thing we did put together
and again this has been a team effort is
um you know researchers always
actually got to have good training
materials if you're going to implement
this into your institution you've got to
show people how to use these
appropriately
um and so one thing we try to create is
this one pager
um is it something that we give to all
the all the
uh the pis in their labs when they are
going through our training programs on
i can just basically asep the techniques
and road in surgery
um and so i thought it would be good to
kind of highlight this and i'm more than
happy to share this with anyone who's
interested
i mean listen to this talk directly but
essentially just goes over the benefits
of the cling film
and the and the aluminum foil again we
can only talk about press and seal
and rental trap because that's all we
studied right now i know there's several
other products but
um from a scientific standpoint these
are the only two that we evaluated
and so we can say that the seriality was
validated for up to 28 days
for present seal and up to six months
for aluminum foil
uh next to that we can say that um
it's sterile directly from the box um
without any other processing uh
techniques you know um
such as gas sterilization it's it's not
needed it's very cost effective
um and it's it's a it's available you
know in your neighborhood
store down grocery store down the street
again these benefits of being able to
visualize the patient doing surgery and
also help with the thermal regulation
also make it very appealing
and it definitely helps with improved
compliance for aseptic use
amongst our animal our animal users
so very helpful um some of the best
practices you know some questions we get
are
do i need to remove a piece of the press
and seal every time before i use it and
the answer to that
is is yes um so we recommend you remove
actually about 30 centimeters from the
roll and discard that
and then when you pull that next piece
out that's the that's going to be your
your your clean kind of aseptic piece
that you want to use for
if you're draping the animal or putting
on any type of uh
instrumentation say anesthesia machine
and that's
for both press and seal and for the
reynolds wrap foil
um and so some some some really
important things to
just to think about but again i thought
it would just be really helpful to kind
of show you just a nice summary of
everything that was said
said in one page and this is something
we found to be very effective when
going for uh training opportunities for
our scientists and investigators
uh one thing i do want to also share is
one of our colleagues who's been very
um invested in this and extremely
helpful and getting a lot of these
publications getting
studies done or our colleagues down at
utsa
down in texas they have an outstanding
resource and web page that has videos
pdf handouts uh training modalities
on how to actually use the press and
seal how do you drape the table
how do you take it out the box um and so
forth so this is something i definitely
want to highlight and
and i recommend um folks you know you
don't have to reinvent the wheel you can
just reference this
uh this page um and i think you'll find
it'll be very helpful when trying to
incorporate this into your facilities um
i
finally want to want to also provide a
couple of references
um out there that also just kind of
support press and seal
um and also rodent just in general
rodent aseptic surgery
i mean just some of the the guidelines
and updates going on
um finally i definitely want to take the
time to acknowledge
all the partners working within this so
nationwide children's hospital
uh the ohio state university their
university laboratory
resources group a lot of this this work
was completed
um at ohio state with that team also
i'm in collaboration with utsa um and
our other partners and colleagues i'm at
the university of louisville and
university of rochester
um and and i'll definitely a special um
shout out to the preston seal dream team
as they call themselves
it's definitely been a very nice
collaborative effort and i think
that's been our goal is how do we come
up with some
some practices and recommendations that
anyone can take and implement at their
institution to really help
not only with compliance issues and
decreasing that
when it comes to rodent aseptic
techniques
but also providing some some useful kind
of
general information for pis to be able
to use in those solo surgeons to be
successful
so they don't have any kind of
post-operative complications using
things that are very
very readily available and economical
and so at this time that concludes this
talk
and will definitely i am definitely
available to answer any questions
provide any resources
that anyone might be interested in
obtaining any of the publications
or more insight on the data and things
of that nature please
please feel free to contact me i'll send
any questions or comments at any time
and this is my contact information happy
to happy to help in any way and continue
to
collaborate to everyone out there so i
hope you've enjoyed this talk and
take care and stay safe